i consider two biggest factors
to focus on goals
and preparation
to accomplish those goals
hello my name is cesar camaro
i am from venezuela i am a father of two
girls
today with my wife we live in panama in
central america i have worked as a
project manager for more than 12 years
in telecommunications and ata businesses
currently
i am working as a pmo process manager
for an electoral solution company
establishing processes
for projects around the region
i have researched
some online companies
and i found a listing online as a good
option
i tried my first certification course
and obtained the certification i was
pursued
now after that success
i am starting other certification scores
just to keep my knowledge
in the professions one of my initial
concerns about online training was about
the clarity of the instructors speak in
addition of the knowledge
at simple lurk i found excellent english
speakers in every topic they explained
the matter very clearly and with
outstanding pronunciation which made it
easier the understanding of the topic
my career jumped at a new level
after obtaining my pmi
risk management professional
certification
i obtained my current
job because of the certification
about my knowledge about project
management processes and risk management
the obtaining of my certifications for
risk management professional
was a highly differentiator
from other professionals in the hybrid
process
i consider my knowledge can be applied
in a person's life
in fact
my wife always says i want to be a
project manager even at home
well you know definitely
is a challenge
and also
a thin effort
a challenge because i need to invest
personal time
at night to secure to keep the balance
with work and the family
and also
a team effort
because my family supported me a lot
people learning is my secret
i have reserved
from my schedule
two sessions at night
on a weekly basis
just to keep on learning you know
today is the time to increase your
knowledge and especialize in technical
and non-technical skills
some of the knowledge we are acquiring
today will be considered baseline in the
future start learning today what will be
needed tomorrow
start learning at simple learn
[Music]
you